okay I just have to say something
if you have lip filler Botox
fake lashes fake hair
I can't the nails done
and you're gonna come on and tell me how
the cost of living is too high
and you're living paycheck to paycheck I
don't want to hear it
you don't have to do that
now I know a lot of women see these as
necessities
it's not a necessity I know this is
crazy but you can't tell me how you
can't afford if I could see your
forehead not moving when you smile
because you clearly have botox
all that stuff equates to like two grand
a month
now these men have to come in and
maintain you
you will get no sympathy no sympathy
from me a few of all that done thank you
that is my daily rant